- Watch it man!
- Oh shit dude, are you gonna be okay?
- Fuck you.
- Dude, are you making
this little bitch cry?
- Watch it dude!
Oh dude, Anderson.
- Zach, what the fuck is up dude.
Dude, I haven't seen you in forever dude.
- I know.
- Oh my God, you almost hit this guy
with your car.
It's so funny dude. (laugh)
- I know dude. Look how mad he looks.
Fucking douche bag.
- Aw, little douche bag,
is your pussy crying
tears of sadness dude?
- I could have been hurt.
(both laughing)
- Dude, I'm fucking starving.
Let's get that Asada.
Hey, excuse me man, pardon me.
Hey, are you just standing here right now?
Or are you gonna order?
- [Male Voice] What's up.
- Ehhhh, como se dice I want like
three carne asada tacos
but not spicy okay.
What do you want dude?
- Hey, what the fuck is lingue?
So delicious.
- I think my hat's
giving me a headache man.
- Yeah, dude, this joint's giving me
like a fucking pulsing migraine.
- So dude, like how have you been?
- Good dude.
Good dude.
Um, not doing much, I'm just uh,
my dad's making me take this super intense
commercial acting class.
Says I need to find a positive outlet
for all this energy I have.
- Oh fuck your dad dude.
And like, he can't like fucking tell
you what to do, you know?
- Oh, actually he sorta can,
he's sorta supporting me right now.
- Oh.
- But luckily I'm like basically
the best actor in my class.
- Nice dude, that's so cool dude.
- Yeah.
- That also sort of like
sucks though, you know.
- Yeah.
- Yeah dude.
- Wait, what about you though?
You look fucking ripped.
Fucking lean beef over there.
- Oh thanks dude.
Basically the only thing I'm adjusting
right now is fucking coconut water.
- That shit's mad refreshing bro.
- Fuck yeah dude.
Yeah, I just bought like a case of Zeco,
like stuck that shit in the fridge.
That shit is my fucking juice son.
- Nice dude.
Dude, this is great you know.
Like just hard ass chillin.
- Yeah dude.
- I feel like we haven't done this much
since you turned into a little bitch
and started hanging out with your
girlfriend all the time.
- Yeah man.
- How is she?
- Dude, she fucking died dude.
- No shit?
- Yeah dude, she was like texting
and driving and she went right
into a construction zone.
- Holy shit dude!
That's some heavy shit.
- Yeah dude.
- When did that happen?
- Dude, yesterday dude.
- Holy shit dude!
Are you like okay?
- It's like funny that you ask dude.
Cuz like no dude.
I don't think I am.
(laughing)
- Fuck (crying)
Sorry that my laugh has
been all fucked up today.
- Cool.
- (Laugh) Do you wanna swapsies man?
Like, I'll try the carnezas?
- Yeah for sure dude, here.
- Oh fuck dude, look, douchebag is back.
- Oh shit dude.
That dudes gotta learn.
- Fuck yeah.
- Hey where's your fucking bike bro?
- Are you serious?
(laughing)
What the fuck is wrong with you assholes?
- Oh my God.
- That's so funny dude.
- Look at how mad he looks.
- Oh my God, he's gonna cry.
He's such a little bitch.
(laughing)
- Hey dude. Fucking condolences bro.
- Thanks.
- Wanna get out of here?
- Fuck yeah I do.
(upbeat music)
- Oh fuck dude, it's that guy.
- Oh shit, dude does he look pissed?
- He looks so pissed.
(laughing)
- [Guy] Are you serious?
(upbeat music)
- Hey you guys, thanks for watching
our show Bro-Dependent on CC Studios.
- Yeah, if you like
liked it and enjoyed it
then fucking subscribe to
Comedy Centrals' YouTube channel
and there will be like further videos
and what not.
- Yeah, click the links to like
check out new episodes.
- And if you have like an opinion
don't fucking swallow that shit
like fucking comment dude.
- Voice that shit.
Comment in the comments section.
- Cuz there are people that are
fucking interested.